on regarde ça de plus en plus mais c'est
quasiment impossible la crise qui
perdure semble sans issue dans son
studio de radio de Montréal Jean
ernest-pierre peine à cacher son
désarroi face à sa patrie c'est plus
fort que nous
depuis des mois le Canada se montre
réticent à prendre la tête d'une aide
internationale les solutions à la crise
de sécurité doivent être menées par et
pour les Haïtiens aujourd'hui Mélanie
jolie arrive avec un compromis
toujours pas question d'envoyer de
troupes le Canada va plutôt ouvrir un
bureau de coordination de l'aide
internationale en République Dominicaine
pour répondre aux besoins de la police
nationale haïtienne qui demeurera la
seule force de l'ordre à intervenir sur
le territoire
que les étrangers ont peur d'eux ce ne
serait pas suffisant pour venir à bout
des gangs criminels du genre nest pierre
il suffirait que l'armée canadienne ou
en tout cas des policiers canadiens
viennent donner un petit coup de pouce
et ça aiderait énormément mais à
distance c'est waitensi c'est pas facile
le mandat que le Canada s'est donné
c'est une mission complexe 17 ancienne
ambassadeur canadien à part au prince
parce qu'il faut d'abord recruter des
policiers sur le terrain est minimum
d'environ 10.000 policiers actuellement
il y en a 4000 il faudra peut-être
sortir des sentiers battus si le Canada
veut vraiment parvenir à ses fins
de coopération internationale c'est de
payer les salaires des gens mais je me
dis à un moment donné si le Canada veut
quitty puisse recruter des policiers
faudra peut-être donner une prime à
l'embauche
Ernest Pierre lui se dit toujours prêt à
aider son pays si le Canada voulait
exemple préparer des gens de la société
civile
à aller en Haïti avec une formation oui
moi j'aurais été pour Ottawa c'est une
avenue moins risqué et moins coûteuse
que l'émission de maintien de la paix
que le Canada a mené en Haïti dans le
passé mais c'est une solution qui
demandera de la patience et le
gouvernement assure que l'aide offerte
aujourd'hui restera en place tant que ce
sera jugé nécessaire ici Valérie gammach
Radio-Canada
Ottawa